thanks for joining us America we're glad
you are here Dan is in York Pennsylvania
hi Dan how are you good how about
yourself Dave better than I deserve
what's up I'm calling to get your
opinion or your thoughts on in network
marketing or level multi-level marketing
namely the company Amway okay all right
they're the oldest and I guess they're
probably still the largest they've been
around for a site the last I heard they
were like number 37 and number 38 in
launch of entrepreneurial companies oh
oh total companies or MLMs I heard
entrepreneurial companies so it might be
multi-level company I don't know what I
don't know how you measure what an
entrepreneurial company is mine might be
an entrepreneurial company and we're not
an MLM so I'm not sure about that I know
Amway is probably the oldest they used
to be the largest I'm not sure if
they've dwindled down or not but anyway
they they're kind of set the standard
back in the day okay
like when I was a kid so how old are you
I am actually gonna be 24 next week okay
and what do you want to do with your
life when you're 50 what do you want to
be doing I want to be retired okay you
want to do nothing
well not doing nothing but I'm going to
pursue some kind of teaching career and
music I'm a drummer I've been playing my
drums the whole life and that's really
what I'd like to deal with as I'm living
okay so you would love to be a
professional drummer and make a
bazillion dollars doing that if you
could just write your own script right
now sure okay that's why that's what I'm
asking
multi-level is selling and the people
that make good money
in multi-level like a hundred thousand
dollars a year or more are sales
managers and recruiters what you do for
a living if you're making six figures in
a multi-level or a net
work marketing program is you are
recruiting people training them and
replacing them because the fallout is
huge right because by and large they
hire people who are not people that want
to be salespeople and most of them don't
make it so your turnover is very very
high and you are constantly recruiting
hiring training recruiting hiring
training if that's what you want to do
for the living for a living for the next
ten years multi-level network marketing
could very well lead you into a
six-figure income and you would be in
control of your destiny that's the good
news the bad news is it doesn't sound
like that's what you want to do yeah I
was really hoping to do it as kind of as
a part-time job as I'm working full-time
at my wife's working full-time the kind
of propel ourselves through the baby
steps here's the thing you're amazing
the way they pitch the stuff in network
marketing is you see becoming wealthy
and retired because you actually
mentioned that earlier right when I ask
where you want to be I want to be
retired you saw yourself as wealthy
doing multi-level you don't accidentally
part-time turn a multi-level thing into
a million dollars right it doesn't just
it doesn't just like you show up and you
go get through your friends in this
thing and it turns into a million
dollars it's seven to ten years of very
hard work as a master recruiter trainer
and manager of sales people those are
the people that make seven figures I've
got several friends that make a million
dollars a year and I've got a like a
thousand or two thousand or ten thousand
people that I've met that we're in it
for three months that are not anymore
okay but I actually know more than five
people in network marketing they make
that have made a million dollars a year
at one time or another but they didn't
do that part-time and they didn't do
that part-time for three years and then
full-time for two years they became
professional motivators professional
sales trainers professional managers and
hires or sales people and they have
Rhino thick skin because people come and
go every 20 minutes right and they don't
get their feelings hurt when everybody's
mad and turning
they just go get another one they just
go get another one and that's that
business there's nothing evil or wrong
with the business but if you think
you're going to hire three people and
they're all three going to be with you
ten years from now you are kidding
yourself in any business for that matter
but multi-level for sure okay you know
I've had I got 700 folks working here
I've got 30 of them that have been with
me more than 15 years out of 700 and I
got I got probably 400 they used to work
here sometime during the last 25 years
that don't work here anymore you know so
then that's a traditional business model
that's not a high turnover bought
business model that's where I'm actually
paying people a salary they don't have
to sell anything they just show up and
get money you know and so it's a
different thing so you got to decide
what you want to do and if this is in
line with your career goals and with
your personality style and what you want
to do for a living and you don't mind
the high rejection and you don't mind
motivation and you don't mind turnover
and you don't mind that stuff you can do
very well at this and again I've got
some friends that have I'm just over the
hill over here I got a friend that was a
whatever they call him a double black
diamond or whatever it is in in Amway
and he's made million dollars a year and
am away for years for years and does
very very well but you know for every
one of those there's 10,000 that stayed
two months and left and made all their
friends mad right and so because they
call on all their friends and try to
sell them something they didn't want or
something like that I don't know so have
some class if you're going to do it and
if you're going to do it lean into it
and say this is going to be my career as
a part-time job look at it and just go
okay what's the typical person make in
three months and get some real numbers
not what you can make if you're a
superstar but what is the typical person
making 3 months you probably make more
Drive and lift right probably then I
mean check it out for yourself if you're
good you might have a good little
salesman down inside that drummer I
don't know you know and you you know I'm
not talk you out of it I'm just saying
don't just say oh I'm gonna go make some
money because these people all make
money that I'm talking to because that's
not the way it works
it is a there's a particular skill set
that you will develop or have to to
become wealthy in those world in that
world and there's nothing wrong with it
at all
but to you know teachers got in this and
a an old teacher got in this look at
this old teacher maybe well that'll
teach her there not being a teacher
anymore they became a sales manager and
you know this guy used to be a you know
he used to be a construction worker and
look what he's doing now when he's not a
construction worker anymore now he's a
sales manager that's what he does for a
living and you know so when they put up
the examples of quote regular people
unquote who become wealthy they did not
use regular people's skill sets to
become wealthy they use the skill set
necessary to grow that particular
business and a construction worker can
become an IT professional if they want
to be a teacher can leave and become a
doctor if they want to be
you can change careers and become
successful in another career and that's
what's happened there it wasn't that you
know that this teacher used to make you
know forty two thousand dollars a year
and now look they make four hundred
twenty thousand a year yeah well they're
not a teacher anymore
they're sales manager what they do and
high turnover situation so that's what
you're facing and my family's good
people they're good good folks around
there they need a lot of people the Lord
they're strong Christians most of them
so I'm not mad at them but you just need
to know what you're getting in on and
what it's gonna take for you to succeed
and whether it fits your goals long term
is this your career goal or not this is
the Dave Ramsey show